et la crise sanitaire a mis en lumière
la fragilité de l'hôpital en france
selon les soignants qui de l'avenir du
système de santé ils sont à nouveau dans
la rue aujourd'hui par rassemblement
parisien vient de commencer à l'appel
notamment du collectif santé en danger
il appelle à la réouverture du dialogue
avec le gouvernement on va revendre tout
de suite notre reporter sur place dans
le cortège parisien nadège abderrazak
bonjour nadège alors quelle est
l'ambiance actuellement
[Applaudissements]
et on en a ras-le-bol de ces guignols
qui ferment nos usines nos écoles et nos
hôpitaux ces landais a cependant accordé
à aujourd'hui lors de cette
manifestation qui a débuté en début
d'après midi qui réunit 1 quelques
milliers de manifestants venus d'un peu
partout en france de mayenne de maine et
loire ou encore de la région rhône-alpes
l'objectif de ces manifestants et six
présences et de défendre et l'hôpital
public de réclamer plus de moyens et la
réouverture de l'isch vous propose à ce
sujet d'écouté à des manifestants que
l'on a interrogé total dans cette
situation où on nous impose un pass
sanitaires et bien on supprime les lie
donc là il y en a cinq mille 700 camps
ont encore été supprimées on en annonce
d'autres et c'est parfaitement
incohérent avec la situation que nous
vivons on est dans un monde de procédure
on est en train de casser le métier
soignants alors les plans blancs existe
on enlève de plus en plus des soignants
et ça fait des années que ça dure
bientôt il y aura peut-être une manif y
aura plus que des chômeurs soignants
peut-être ou libéraux c'est parce qu'on
veut l'hôpital public doit avoir des
moyens est actuellement les moyens du
ségur sont insuffisants nettement ils
ont essayé de rattraper le coup mais ça
suffit pas ils le savent très bien en
tout cas le gouvernement le sait très
bien donc je demande à olivier ferrand
et à d'autres comme tous mes collègues
qui sont là d'arrêter de nous mettre la
pression procédurale de l'europe pour
faire des métiers puis exercé des
métiers de bureaucrates
alors tendre ce cortège on retrouve des
soignants évidemment mais aussi des
instituteurs et des étudiants ainsi que
des élus politiques plusieurs députés
ont fait le déplacement de mayenne je
vous propose d'en écouter deux d'entre
eux
oui le plein fouet la désertification
médicale parce que nos soigné au centre
épuisé parce que dans ma ville à laval
les urgences ont fermé le soir à 18h30
ça veut dire que l'après 18h30 les
patients aient été orientés vers
d'autres hôpitaux d'autres départements
vous pensez bien que c'est une perte de
chance vous pensez bien que ça n'est pas
acceptable
aujourd'hui cette présence elle est
légitime tout simplement parce que nous
portons la voix de notre territoire la
voix d'un territoire qui veut un égal
accès pour laquelle l égal accès aux
soins pour tous nous voulons préserver
nos hôpitaux parce que nos hôpitaux sont
aussi un symbole important de
l'attractivité de nos territoires et nos
hôpitaux sont menacés donc nous sommes
là pour les défendre
une délégation de mayenne a été reçue au
sein du ministère de la santé aux
alentours de 14h et dans une demie or ce
sera au tour de la délégation de
l'intersyndicale de rencontrer un
représentant du ministère de la santé
alors il espère que le gouvernement que
olivier vers ans aura autant de répondre
à leurs revendications en tout cas les
entendre pour l'instant donc voilà il
estime que l heure est grave qu'ils font
face à une cinquième bague de covin
alors si il ya un moment où il ne faut
pas les oublier bien c'est bien
maintenant
merci n'a déjà pour toutes ces
précisions